діаграма показує вам клас a
робітничий клас Париж після
пором слона Джулса
сьогодні у нас були студенти
українці здобували освіту у Франції с
їхні батьки зі своїми вчителями вони
зараз майже 10 000 і це
кількість збільшується з кожним днем
нам важливо першими побачити один одного
знати потреби та задовольняти їх
ми зробили це постійно
з українським міністром
освіта, з якою я розмовляю
регулярно, що я все ще там бачив
кілька днів у рамках консультації
Європейську освіту ми всі отримали
міністри освіти європейських країн
зв’яжіться з ним, щоб слухати його знати
на його потреби вони певним чином відповідають
координується на європейському рівні та
тоді тут, у Франції, зробіть це певним чином
дуже практичний і, якщо можливо, ефективний
тому уважний до того, що є
очевидно, навчання всіх
дітей
У нас була відеоконференція з
Міністр освіти України
ми також хотіли їм це сказати
що ми з ними солідарні
все, що відбувається
що цінності свободи рівності
Братство мають дуже велике застосування
конкретний за таких обставин, як
ці
[Музика]